it was a prickly
about you refer
yes okay let's get started I'm apt Ike
research professor here at the Center
for International Science and Technology
Policy at George Washington University's
Elliott School which is where you are
now and I want to welcome you on behalf
of our Center and the Center for science
and democracy of the Union of Concerned
Scientists they are co-sponsoring this
event together with the George
Washington University
Sean Otto our speaker here is an
award-winning science advocate he's a
writer he's a man of many talents them
really get to know him he's quite a
quite an impressive guy a writer a
teacher and a speaker he's a co-founder
of science debate org and for which he
received the I Triple E USA National
distinguished public service award he's
advised science debate efforts in other
countries as well he's a novelist and a
filmmaker his novel sins of our fathers
which is a literary thriller was a
finalist in the LA Times Book Prize and
his film the House of Sand and Fog which
is something I saw actually several
years ago before I met John it's a
terrific film and I would suggest it's a
it's available on Amazon and on YouTube
and I would suggest that if you have a
chance you you view it rent it and view
it it was nominated for three Academy
Awards it stars Jennifer Connelly and
Ben Kingsley and he was the co-wrote the
screenplay for it his latest book is the
one that you see displayed up here and
outside on the table call
the war on science and that's what he's
talking about today Sean lives in in
Minnesota and has an environmental house
and has it been powered to sell a solar
and wind power and as I said he's a very
interesting guy he's gonna the way we're
gonna do this Sean is going to do a
PowerPoint presentation and then he and
I are going to have a conversation and
we'll then open it up to Q&A and after
that we'll have some time to mingle and
enjoy the refreshments that are left so
without further taking away from his
time let me give you a shot thanks al
and thanks everyone for coming
representative McCollum let me know that
she is not sure if she can make it due
to the voting schedule in Congress today
they're trying to move several bills but
we'll see if she'll be able to join us
for the conversation later as well
so as al mentioned I was involved in an
organization called science debate org
which is still around and I would
encourage you to sign on if you have not
as a supporter of science debate it's
basically a non-profit 501c3 effort to
get the candidates for president
primarily but also other public office
in the United States to talk about the
big science and technology health and
environmental issues that face all of us
and as you'll see from my presentation
this is an issue that is only going to
grow in importance as we move forward in
time what I tried to focus on throughout
the course of this is bridging a gap
that exists in large part between what
we're able to do with science and our
ability to think and talk about it in
our public policy process and so that's
essentially kind of what the war on
science started out
grew out of that effort the book is
really an observation on the court
relationship between science and
democracy science is a great force for
equality and if you care about justice
you have to care about science and
democracy and it's an effort to defend
democracy from a rise in
authoritarianism so a number of people
wonder if there really is a war on
science at the American Association for
the Advancement of science meeting last
fall there was a a panel questioning
that and I would put I would would
spoiler alert yeah yes there is there's
a war on science right now and and I'd
like to give you some examples from our
politics politics politics by the way or
not causing the war on science and and
for reasons I'll explain it a little bit
science is not partisan here but they
are certainly participating in it two
years old two and a half years old the
child a beautiful child went to have the
vaccine and came back and a week later
got a tremendous fever got very very
sick now is autistic so anti science
politics like this somehow over the
course of the last twenty years have
become completely acceptable in an
American public dialogue that's
something that when I was a kid for
instance would not have been tolerated
somebody made a statement that was
blatantly that blatantly flew in the
face of what we know from science pretty
much be the end of their political
career that doesn't happen anymore and
the reason that it doesn't leads us to a
curious examination of really what is
going on in American politics and why
that could be what has changed in the
public in the public's view of science
to make that possible now it's not just
happening on the right although many in
the science community seem to think that
it is but it's also happening sometimes
on the left and I'll show some examples
of that Bernie Sanders for instance has
the most aggressive climate plan of all
the candidates for president is broadly
embraced and supported by climate
scientists at the same time
he's against nuclear power he supports
alternative medicine and he's for GMO
labeling all of which have nuances and
elements of them that are not anti
science but that are informed often by a
lot of anti science beliefs like the
idea not supported by science that
genetically modified crops are not
healthy to eat this isn't just happening
in presidential races is also happening
in Congress consider congressman Shimkus
who's chairman of the House Subcommittee
on Environment and the economy in as
he's participated in this hearing on
climate change declares its time to be
over man will not destroy this earth
this earth will not be destroyed by a
flood and I appreciate having panelists
here who are men of faith and we can get
into the theological discourse of of
that position but I do believe God's
Word is infallible unchanging perfect to
other issues mr. chairman today we have
about 388 parts per million in the
atmosphere I think in the areas of the
dinosaurs where we had most flora and
fauna we were probably at 4,000 parts
per million there is a theological
debate that this is a carbon starved
planet now I don't know how many of you
noticed the gilded scientific report
that he was waving his hand there but
the question is why in a committee
hearing where we are discussing matters
of national import presumably talking
about evidence is he waving a Bible to
begin with why go to ad ology instead of
evidence and why is that a thority in
this particular case my father read the
Bible to our family when I was a kid
over the dinner table for about a year
and I don't recall the part about carbon
in the Bible maybe I just missed it that
day this is all happening also happening
in state legislatures across the country
here's a rather famous example from a
couple of years ago where the North
Carolina legislature banned sea-level
rise
this was essentially a move again in the
climate war and but it's a problem
because it was more reminiscent of say
Mao's China than the United States where
local officials had to go to the state
legislature in the central state
government in order to get approval and
use the numbers that they provided not
actual numbers from science when making
zoning decisions roadbed Heights
decisions and things like that in
development close to the ocean this is
also happening in city governments for
instance Snowmass last summer banned
fluoride the use of fluoride over
concerns that it it might be a bad for
your health
CDC considers it one of the greatest
public health advances of the 20th
century it's not just in the United
States though anti science like this
beliefs or public policies that are
completely contradicted by the evidence
is really spreading worldwide Canada
during the harper administration who
patterned a lot of their policies on
some of the bush administration policies
by limiting what scientists could say
and and their interactions with the
press and placing ideological appointees
over them in closing libraries and
scientific enterprises engendered a
demonstration on their Capitol Hill in
Ottawa talking about no science no
evidence no truth no democracy it was a
mock funeral for democracy and science
but this is all this also has happening
in Australia where cities representing
about half a million people have
recently banned fluoride in France where
there are new outbreaks of measles
because the low vaccination rates over
fears about autism the United Kingdom
also has a resurgence of problems with
the anti-vaccine movement the United
Kingdom is of course the birthplace of
the
a vaccine movement Poland and Germany
where there's a resurgence of teaching
of creationism in public school science
classes Ireland where Dublin also banned
fluoride Israel where the Health
Minister who does not have a background
in science recently banned fluoride for
the entire country Nigeria where of
course groups like Boko Haram whose very
name means Western knowledge is
forbidden are reacting in a in their
version of a right-wing reaction against
science and China where there's a
burgeoning environmental movement and at
the same time a burgeoning movement
against genetically modified crops which
are seen as some kind of stocking horse
from the West so why is this spreading
particularly why is it spreading
throughout many times Western
democracies which have traditionally
been associated with science with
freedom with free thought with critical
thinking with individual rights all of
those things that seem to have been
associated with science there's
something happening that's quite odd
here and that's what this exploration
tries to get at and the best place to
start is really understanding why it
matters so science as I said a moment
ago is really the great equalizer it is
the one thing that stands between say
two brothers with as much power as these
two brothers have Charles and David Koch
and two brothers that have as much as
these two have my nephews in Chicago now
in theory these two sets of brothers in
the United States should have the same
access to justice the same access to
potentially to education or to
employment at least to voting and
science is the one equalizer that
neutralizes the vast size of the
megaphone of the brothers on the left
side of the screen and provides an
opportunity to the brothers on the
right this is based in some core ideas
that really date back to the very very
founding of the United States Thomas
Jefferson said wherever the people are
well informed they can be trusted with
their own government and there is really
the crux of some of the problem that
we're running into if you have ever been
down to the Library of Congress you will
have seen probably Thomas Jefferson's
library that's recreated there nice
round space round bookcases and which
contained virtually the entirety of
human knowledge at the time and he had
read all of those books and contained
that in his mind he was a scientist and
an attorney sort of like Francis Bacon
was and that was a possible idea back
then the well-informed voter but what
happens now nearly a quarter cent nearly
a quarter millennia later when science
has continued to advance and is not at
all possible for one person to know even
a fraction of all that there is to know
how do we have well-informed voters that
are able to govern themselves
successfully in a democracy in the age
dominated by complex science and
technology that's the rub that we're
bumping up against well in order to come
up with this idea for democracy to
convince other Enlightenment nations to
not intercede in the Revolutionary War
Jefferson reached for the greatest
thinking of what he called his Trinity
of three greatest men to come up with an
argument that would convince him to stay
out he went to the thinking of Isaac
Newton inventor at the time of physics
who said a man may imagine things that
are false but he can only understand
things that are true and this is part of
where we're getting into trouble today
because if you take out your cell phone
and turn it over and unscrew the
Phillips screws that are on the back
wait a minute there are no Phillips
screws on the back it's hard to have
know-how it's hard to understand things
that are true when science and
technology have become so complex that
is difficult for the average person to
break them down a generation ago you
could
down at your kitchen table and you could
buy a kit and you could make a radio
that's no longer true with cell phones
so at the moment that that cell phones
which like flying brooms are made by
people close to Dawei wearing long robes
and uttering strange incantations right
at the moment that science becomes
indistinguishable from magic we become
vulnerable to disinformation campaigns
because science by its very nature must
become in a way a function of belief and
it's what do you believe in scientists
choose to believe in journals in the
peer-review process but even those are
vulnerable as we've seen lately from
certain for-profit journals and journals
for hire
Jefferson next turn to Francis Bacon
like him both a scientist and an
attorney the Attorney General of England
who sought to circumscribe the power of
the king of the monarch and he worked
very hard to build a lot of the core
ideas that that Jefferson relied on in
creating democracy and he said that what
a man had rather were true he more
readily believes which is one of the
reasons that he worked hard to create
inductive reasoning and the method that
we came to call Western science drying
of course on Imanol item and and other
Muslim scholars that had worked on on
developing observational based science
before that but he saw that as a way to
guard against confirmation bias our
tendency to see what we want in the
environment and instead of starting like
Descartes did from the top down our
thinking I think therefore I am
start with nature and see what nature
has to say about it and confirm your
observations there and build up from
that and then Jefferson turned to a man
that conservatives really appreciate
these days John Locke and John Locke
aside from his conservative by today's
standards credentials also was seeking
to solve a problem he looked at all the
factions of Protestantism that were
happening that had broken down and were
arguing with one another over who had
the true path to God who had the real
knowledge and he decided that there must
be a way to really know what is real
what is knowledge verses as he called it
but faith or opinion so he came up with
three tests intuitive knowledge things
like 2+2 is 4 you know or that here we
go we've got 2 & 2 put them together
that's 4 we can see it intuitively
there's no arguing with it the next
firmest form of knowledge is
demonstrative for instance a feather and
a penny fall at different rates put them
in a vacuum tube i suck out all the air
and then they fall out the same rate
therefore i can conclude that air has an
effect on the way that gravity acts on
these different objects so that's i
built that up from intuitive knowledge
made a deduction or an induction did an
experiment and combined them all to
create demonstrated and demonstrative
knowledge and finally his third was
sensitive knowledge i smell a rose i
look around for a rose but i might be
deceived because i might just be
smelling perfume so sensitive knowledge
our common sense was the least reliable
form of knowledge the kind that most
often deceived us the weakest and
anything that fell short of one of these
was but faith or opinion in other words
anybody could argue about it much like
we have varying factions in political in
the political sphere arguing endlessly
with one another now that science has
begun to break down in society so
finally to guard against that he said
that every argument should be argued in
a way that was similar to a mathematical
theorem grounding the mine or bringing
the mind to the source on which it
bottoms and that's what jefferson really
sought to do in in writing the
Declaration of Independence because his
life really hung on it and it was really
these essential ideas combined that led
to the core functioning idea that in
four
the United States which was that if
anyone can discover the truth for him or
herself using the tools of Reason in
science then no Pope no monarch no
wealthy Lord has any more authority to
govern us than we do ourselves and that
was an argument for a crowdsourced
enlightenment reason to support this new
form of government called democracy
without science the United States would
not have been here so our whole system
is dependent on this kind of thinking
now Jefferson himself fell into common
traps and thought that we all fall into
habit this kind of thinking is not
intuitive it's difficult here's a early
draft of the Declaration of Independence
and you'll notice that in the top of the
second paragraph he wrote we hold these
truths to be sacred and undeniable that
all men are created equal that doesn't
sound quite right does it what he was
doing there was he fell into a mistake a
mistake of thinking in appeal to the
divine we hold these truths to be sacred
and and not an undeniable the moment he
did that he opened the United States up
the argument up to anyone who had a
different faith to argue that no Zaire's
was the more sacred and undeniable truth
they had a greater authority he violated
John Locke's idea of knowledge Benjamin
Franklin who was our leading scientists
at the time took a look at the draft he
gave it to him and Franklin made those
back slashes that edit and that's
Franklin's handwriting writing in the
words self-evident which he was quoting
from his friend David Hume so in this
edit it's arguably the most important
edit in the history of the United States
because it narrowly circumscribed
democracy has a secular form of
government that was independent of and
non judgmental towards religion it did
not make a religious appeal and neither
did a judge religion so in Jefferson's
thinking then
democracy really had a virtuous circle
it began with some governance issue then
we would turn to the educated and
informed mass of the people from whom we
would draw the Congress and that
educated and foreign masa people would
Commission scientific research as
Jefferson did with the Lewis and Clark
expedition to build knowledge about that
governance issue and then based on that
knowledge Congress would debate the best
policy response that's the way it was
supposed to work but what's been
happening over the last 40 to 50 years
and I'll show you how exactly and why
we've had some corruption of that
process instead of the education of
foreign mass of the people vested
interests seek to provide alternative
theories to children and propaganda to
adults for instance seeking to teach
that not evolution but creationism is
really the way that human beings came to
be then based on that instead of turning
to scientific research to build
knowledge we turn to Authority and
ideology for knowledge as much as
representative Shimkus was when he was
waving that gilded scientific report
then instead of debating the best policy
based on that knowledge we debate it
based on dogma and that's a formula for
transforming democracy into
authoritarianism because at that point
then who writes the dogma
the person with the biggest megaphone
instead of turning to knowledge that any
one of US citizens can generate we turn
to received wisdom from those already in
authority but this is not a conservative
or progressive problem in specific
science is not partisan but science is
always political and that's a really
important
distinguish the distinction to keep in
mind the reason is that science creates
knowledge and as Francis Bacon said
knowledge is power because it gives you
the ability to act in the real world to
change the world and when you do that
you are going to either confirm or
disrupt somebody's vested interests and
that is always a political process also
new knowledge about an issue for
instance when and how life begins causes
us to refine our moral ethical and legal
and policy codes in order to respond to
that new knowledge and that is
inherently a political process as well
so there is an economic disruption in an
ideological disruption that science
often poses and we'll see that that is
driving much of what we're experiencing
right now so instead of a left-right
continuum of politics I would invite you
to think about politics more as a plane
with certainly a left-right continuum
between left wing and right wing and
also a top-down continuum between
anti-authoritarian and authoritarian
science is never partisan because it is
both conservative and progressive a
scientist is always going to research
what has been established before that
tradition if you will before they
publish on something or they could
embarrass themselves but they are also
always going to be open to the frontier
where new knowledge is happening the
progressive end of things because that's
how you make your career so it's about
protecting yourself and making your
career you have to be both but science
is decidedly an anti-authoritarian
occupation it takes nothing on faith by
its nature it says show me the evidence
and I will judge for myself so science
does take a position politically though
not in a partisan way now if you think
about American politics in terms of this
plane it becomes possible to imagine
that there could be such a thing as a
liberal conservative and in fact there
once were and there probably still are
it's just hard to talk right now if
you're a liberal conservative because we
are so used to hearing about these
things as opposite ends of a spectrum
but liberal really means open to
evidence open exploration and in
conservative is not exclusive of that
what I would argue is going on in
American politics right now particularly
in the Republican Party is more of this
argument over authoritarianism and the
rise of authoritarianism and those who
view policy is being dictated by
authoritarian sources and those who
don't but this isn't just happening on
for instance climate change or vaccines
or evolution it's happening on a wide
range of topics that are emerging
because of emerging science this globe
with all these blue lines represent
Facebook connections you'll notice for
instance that China is dark we call that
the Great Firewall of China they block
Facebook but they might as well
represent connections between scientists
working over the internet who are no
longer geographically could
geographically constrained to work in
the same lab in the same location at the
same time at the same time we have
vastly increased the number of
scientists working through our
university education system in the last
30 to 40 years so now we have a vast
number in increase in the number of
scientists and a vast increase in the
quality of they're working together to
the point that over the next 40 years we
will be creating as much new knowledge
as we have since the beginning of the
scientific revolution and if you think
about that and you think about some of
the issues listed in this slide and how
many of our past scientific discoveries
have engendered large political
discussions in conflict and gridlock
because of the moral and ethical
implications they've posed or because of
the economic disruptions they've posed
we could be in for a very rocky neck
half-century and we certainly need to
find a new system a better system even
incorporating complex scientific
information into our policy dialogue in
a democracy the system is starting to
break down and we need to find a new
strategy
so the question emerges are the people
still well enough informed to be trusted
with their own government is this
picture works particularly well with
both signs I think you need the most
this guy is going to be voting on all of
these issues and it becomes easy to see
that we have an issue with outreach with
education with that well informed voter
judging from Congress there they are all
working hard in their laptops the answer
is probably not the 535 members of
Congress there are only 11 of them that
have a professional background in
science it's according to the
Congressional Research survey one
microbiologist one physicist one chemist
and eight engineers you know if some of
the pure scientists in the room might
take issue with the eight engineers
Randi I'm sorry but I'm not going there
except for a cheap joke by comparison
how many do you suppose are lawyers who
mostly duck science classes in college
with a 400 by Wow
if I say we got some cynics in this
audience here but you're not far off
sadly it's 211 or 40% 40% of Congress
are attorneys now this is important
because attorneys approach problems of
fact in a distinctly different way they
use science of course but they don't
start from the ground up and see where
the evidence leads they start with a
predetermined conclusion that they seek
to convince you of and then they
selectively use the science that
supports that conclusion and they'll
certainly research all the other science
and and they are aware of it so that
they can argue against it but that
becomes a problem when more and more
issues have vast inputs of knowledge
from science itself
these people are not necessarily
well-equipped to make the best decisions
in in that case especially since
Congress has abolished its science
advisory body the office of Technology
Assessment not abolished defunded I
guess I should be fair but it hasn't
come back in about 20 years and that's a
that's an issue only to the extent that
that you know members now rely on
lobbyists in the internet it fortunately
those two sources always tell the truth
so I think will probably be okay but but
to the extent that they don't we're in
trouble
so where is this where is this battle
coming from in order to understand that
we first really need to understand
what's driving it in society because
those those are the action points where
anti science campaigns can move people
so let's take a quick look at the
broader narrative line of us science
politics I'm really talking about the
emotional movements here it's the
public's attitude about science and the
the lines are red and blue for a reason
as you will see in a moment a little
over a hundred years ago science was
really quickly commercialized that the
new technology was developed a lot of
engineering was done based on science
and vast fortunes were made so as a
source of great economic growth of pride
of new jobs of an American can-do
attitude and it had enjoyed aside from
certain Democrats like William Jennings
Bryan who campaigned against evolution
for its destroying the moral
underpinnings of society otherwise most
people had favorable attitudes toward
science because of this but then
something happened around 1945 with the
explosion of the atomic bomb and that
led the United States into a great moral
reflection in the immediate post-war
years with a lot of even military
generals talking about how they thought
we'd become intellectual Giants but
moral and ethical infants there was a
lot of discussion about whether or not
we had overstepped our ability to
self-govern with our ability to
technologized and whether we had made a
big mistake additionally there was a lot
of fear that began to happen
particularly in 1949 after the Soviet
Union ignited their atom bomb and the
possibility that this could come back
boomerang back and haunt you know again
kill our population began to haunt a lot
of Americans and there was a generation
in many of you in this room I'm sure
we'll recall those Duck and Cover movies
and growing up with the idea that you
could be annihilated at any moment
that fear really crystallized in 1957
with the launch of Sputnik and for the
first time
Vannevar Bush's idea that we should have
a peacetime investment in science was
finally funded and the National Science
Foundation received money and began to
fund government science in peacetime
this also led to a big race not just a
space race but a science race in order
to beat the Soviets to the moon and to
establish American dominance now this
was not just a science objective this
was a political objective that Kennedy
said using the tools of science to
defend democracy as he apprehended that
they really stood to do but something
very interesting happened at that point
in time NSF and other government
granting agencies had to develop methods
of judging grant applications and
otherwise you know you can't just grant
taxpayer money willy-nilly and if you
send it to somebody that has a goofball
grant applications you could open up the
whole program to a lot of criticism
political problems it was fraught with
danger in a lot of ways so they
developed out reasonably and rationally
a system of judging these grant
applications that were judged by other
scientists but what they didn't do in
the school of unintended consequences is
provide for
the same level of public engagement that
scientists had had to make before then
in the years prior to that for instance
people like Edwin Hubble the
cosmologists would travel around the
country and address standing-room-only
crowds of 5000 people talking about what
he'd seen through that telescope on the
top of Mount Wilson and this kind of
public engagement with science had
happened really for about 50 years
suddenly that began to transform because
scientists really did not need to engage
with the public in the same way in order
to get much of their funding much of us
started funneling through universities
tenure system developed that also did
not value public outreach in fact had
some strong disincentives against public
outreach so science became much more
silent starting in this period
unintentionally and for good reason but
with some consequences that we are now
living with around the same time this
post-war period saw a lot of other
changes too particularly in the
application of other technologies that
were developed during the war for
instance the use of DDT which protected
soldiers in the Pacific Islands from
malaria was broadly used throughout the
United States then and this broad use of
chemicals in the environment led to
Rachel Carson's Silent Spring in 1962
really the birth of environmental
science and the environmental movement
in a lot of ways also she became a
massive target of a public relations
campaign by chemical companies and
agrochemical companies that paralleled
in many ways some of the attacks on
climate scientists that we see today so
we saw a splitting off really of petrol
chemical companies whose business models
that had developed prior to the war and
during the war and that they were
seeking to maintain the same level of
production in peacetime now with this
these domestic applications
suddenly potentially being undermined by
the new science that was coming out
started that Rachel Carson's book I was
the tip of the iceberg for so we saw the
beginning of modern war
science about ten years later
fundamentalists really started seeking
seeing objection raising objection to
our growing control over the human
reproductive process the Piniella was
had been out since 1960 roughly and this
cover of Time magazine here from 1978
talked about test-tube baby and
religious conservatives were debating
whether or not test-tube in vitro babies
would have souls to extent that we know
so far they do seem to have souls just
like the rest of us but this is
fundamentalist objection to origins
science be it origins of the cosmos or
origins of us as human beings was
treading on God's turf ironic since
Protestantism is really where much of
Western science originally grew out of
that things did somewhat come full
circle but this discomfort between these
two groups petrochemical companies and
religious conservatives may start
sounding familiar to you in fact the
division between old industry and old
religion on one side and science and
environmentalists on the other side came
to define some of the basis of our
modern political party structure as
Democrats and Republicans realign
themselves around these issues today
anti science is on the right is themed
around the theme of creeping socialism
and it's generally directed at climate
change
evolution reproduction and recently
vaccines under two arguments one is the
HPV concern that eliminating the risk of
cervical cancer is going to encourage
young women to have sex and the other is
that the libertarian concern that the
government doesn't have any business
intruding in our bodies on the left it's
more about hidden dangers in some some
of this is quite justified but when it
gets into anti science it's extending
these concerns in ways that are not
supported by the evidence suspicions of
mainstream medicine
or the idea that cellphones may cause
brain cancer I can tell you based on
physics chemistry and biology that
that's physically impossible you don't
have to worry about your cell phone or
that vaccines may cause autism that
wastes energy plants are driving climate
change that you can that EMF pollution
is making you sick or that Florida and
water is poisoning you or again that
genetically modified crops are unsafe to
eat now there are other political issues
around GMO about whether or not a
company should control a genome or about
the broad use of pesticides but there
are but that has nothing to do with the
science there is no ingredient if we're
talking about GMO labeling GMO is not an
added to ingredient in food it's just
another way of breeding in fact
interesting side note for those of you
who don't know you know you can bombard
seeds with cancer-causing chemicals and
radiation process called mutagenesis in
order to get them to change genetically
and then you can plant those as a
resulting change plants and you can call
that organic so food for thought the
motivation on the right is largely
anti-regulation anti reproductive
control and pro-corporate on the left
the motivation is pro-environment
pro-choice and anti corporate is this
all starting to sound familiar the theme
on the right is liberal scientists with
a socialist agenda want to control your
life and limit your freedom so it's
really about ultimate individualism and
on the on the Left it's impersonal
doctors greedy corporations and
mechanistic scientists hide the real
dangers to health the environment and
the spirit the interesting thing is that
since NSF scientists have really largely
not participate in the public dialogue
on this discussion it's mostly happened
among people who are not working
scientists so this is occurring across
three major battlefields there is an
identity politics war on science being
fought on universities an ideological
war on science being fought by
fundamentalists and Ana dustry allure in
science being fought by corporations who
don't like what science suggests about
profit structure let's take just really
quick brief looks at the three of them
and then we'll get to a couple of
solutions and then Elle and I will we'll
have a conversation and participate with
you in that the first is the identity
politics war on science which really
grew out again post war about this idea
that all truth is subjective and we
should have suspicions of
meta-narratives and meta-narratives are
essentially stories that groups empower
spin in order to retain power and
science is just one of those
meta-narratives sciences
therefore just another way of knowing
equivalent with indigenous knowledge or
alternative medicine or any other way of
knowing that we have now the the problem
with this thinking is that science
itself really is a method that is
designed to strip what is true out of
all of those individual sources of bias
that post-modernism really emphasizes
what is true away from our gender
identity away from our racial identity
away from our cultural or sexual or
political or religious identity so that
we arrive at the kernel that is a
reliable no matter who does the
measuring that's what science was
designed to do by going not to us but to
nature and that's where the humanities
departments who are deemed being deposed
by the science departments in terms of
funding and prestige got it wrong when
they started arguing that science was
subjective and that's where Thomas Kuhn
got it wrong all the apartments still
point to Thomas Kuhn I have a friend who
teaches screenwriting at a university
and was sitting in a classroom because
he's on the tenure committee for a
teacher and he observed her see in the
back and and she was telling the
students that we can't know for sure
that the earth goes around the Sun and
he walked up to her afterwards and he
said that is just kind of a Socratic
question right you're just so you just
trying to draw them out and get them to
engage and be provocative right
they said no we can't really know that
how can we know that the earth goes
around haven't you read thomas kuhn and
structure of scientific revolutions it's
all politics he went to the tenure
committee and said you know is three of
them I can't vote for this person
because she's really disseminating
nonsense and she's not well equipping
people to be good citizens and democracy
how can I support her and they
considered it and they backed her up
because we can't know according to them
whether the earth goes around the Sun so
this is not fantasy this is happening in
many universities across the country
right now but it's decidedly wrong and
that's where these professors have
become confused and laid down a
philosophical groundwork over the last
two generations that is being taken
advantage of by disinformation campaigns
we really shouldn't believe anything
unless it's supported by evidence one
area where this is really coming to
fruition is in journalism where
journalism schools for the last two
generations have taught that there's no
such thing as objectivity now that may
be a good it may be a good idea to
embrace your own bias to acknowledge
that to not say I'm voiding writing with
a voice of objectivity when I do an
article and it's certainly important to
empower disempowered voices because the
more perspectives on a problem that
science has the more likely it is to
arrive at the truth because it's been
tested from a variety of different
points of view but that's not the same
thing as saying that there's no such
thing as subjectivity here it is in the
voice of san diego new reporter
guidelines not to pick on them they're
one of many many publications who do the
same thing but there it is no such thing
as objectivity Linda Ellerbee on the
speaking circuit there's no such thing
as objectivity even Nick Gillespie the
editor-in-chief of reason.com
and Objectivist publication the saying
that there's no such thing as
objectivity so we've got a problem in
journalism when journalism journalists
believe this how are they going to be
able to drill down and actually get at
the objective facts and the objective
truth of something are we devolving into
a pre John Locke era where
all different parties are warring with
one another with equal claims on what's
true and what's not true where it's only
a matter of one's opinion that's just
your opinion we hear often on the news
well here is here it is illustrated in
journalism journalists will say that you
know I'm a generalist I'm not an expert
on anything there are always two sides
to every story I seek truth but I also
seek balance and I seek in order to
present a balanced story I will get to
different points of view I'll talk to a
scientist and then I'll talk to somebody
standing in the corner and see what they
think and it's a more dynamic story if
they don't agree and the idea is is that
somehow you'll flush out the truth in
that process but it doesn't work that
way if you're equating somebody speaking
with knowledge on the one hand and some
Yahoo with an opinion on the other or
worse not a yahoo with an opinion a very
informed person seeking to in convince
you of the rightness of their opinion
that's contradicted by the evidence
so journalists will say there's always
two sides to every story bob says two
plus two is four Julie says two plus two
is six the controversy rages right you
sell newspapers anyway the scientists
will say most times one side is
objectively wrong even though the
reporter says well Julie might have
legitimate reasons for her perspective
scientists will say I can show you with
these four apples that Bob is clearly
right it doesn't matter how julie feels
about it and then of course you have
politics how about a compromise and we
get a new law saying that two plus two
equals five and that's American politics
in a nutshell these days the problem
with this is that it is reliant on the
journalistic practice of false balance
this equation on one half of the screen
of a scientist speaking with the
accumulated experience of thousands of
scientists conducting tens of thousands
of experiments working sometimes with
billions of data points representing all
that knowledge to the public so that
they can make an informed public policy
decision and on the other half of the
screen you have somebody that is highly
motivated to convince the public of the
rightness of their position and they're
probably much more articulate at
because the bar for them they feel is
higher so they all work as hard as they
can to be convincing as possible what
that does in our public policy dialogue
however it skews the whole dialogue
towards more extreme positions by
driving us away from what's supported by
evidence and knowledge and inordinate ly
providing a voice to knowledge that or
to opinion that is not supported by
knowledge all right
then we've got the ideological war on
science which journalists often fail to
take on because of this concern about
balance or about selling newspapers and
this too in its modern form began after
it began in the post-war period although
really the ideological conflicts with
science date back to Galileo and the
priests that refused to even look
through his telescope to see the
evidence that he was pointing to and
talking about but here after the
Russians detonated their bomb in 1949
Billy Graham took to the road and talked
about how society was going through a
moral nosedive how we are elevating man
and we're taking God off of his stool
and the in society was beginning to
crumble because of it and it was all due
to science at the same time we as
science advanced a decade later we had
television and a lot of evangelicals saw
this as a great opportunity to exercise
the commission of Matthew to go
therefore and make disciples of all
nations and take advantage of this new
medium of television to convert people
to the Evangel evangelism and in fact to
encourage them to run for office to
instill evangelical values in democracy
James Dobson declared the 1990s a civil
the beginning of a civil war on values
and recently the other day Franklin
Graham Billy Graham's son was preaching
in Saint Paul where I was from Ethel on
the Capitol and he was encouraging
people to run for public
as if they are a pro-life and against
gay marriage he said that society is in
a moral nosedive virtually echoing his
father's words from 1949 so some things
have not changed in the relationship
between fundamentalists and science then
there is an industrial war on science
which journalists also failed to take on
and the industrial war on science tends
to be about regulation regulation where
science has provided us with some
information that's been commercialized
in some way or another and then about
ten years down the road it provides new
information saying wait a minute we've
got some unintended consequences here we
ought to take a look at we got to
regulate this the business is built up
on that older science don't like that
and seek to protect their profit model
and we wind up with science fighting
science so there are all these different
aspects of regulation where we see
attacks by industry on scientists and on
the known science in these particular
areas and in a few others for example in
1968 Stanford Research Institute which
is now become a private Research
Institute was largely serving economic
development for corporations they
actually did a study for the American
Petroleum Institute a final report
talking about how significant
temperature changes are almost certain
to occur by the year 2000 and they could
bring about climactic changes this was
1968 I'd say they nailed it pretty well
and the petroleum companies that were
members of the American Petroleum
Institute knew about this at that point
in time in 1990s as the Kyoto Protocol
was being discussed to limit carbon
emissions a number of oil companies and
other activists in that same vein public
relations firms and others got together
and created the global science
communications action plan and they laid
out what in 1998 what has now become a
series of very familiar talking points
that we hear over and over emphasizing
as you'll see here the uncertainties
uncertainties calling it a question the
validity of viewpoints are supporting
the validity of viewpoints that
challenge the current conventional
wisdom there's more uncertainties and
hearing to making mainstream science
appear to be out of touch with reality
to the extent that we can cause a
controversy we can take advantage of the
belief that debate is healthy but it
goes back to the false balance argument
because if one side of the debate is
informed by knowledge and the other is
informed by opinion or some other
motivation it's not a fair fight it's
not an even-handed debate journalists of
course feed into this because of their
focus on balance and that's why it was
developed that way in 2008 we noticed
the paucity of discussion of big science
issues and I'm coming right towards the
end here by these top five TV news
anchors Matthew Chapman my co-founder at
science debate and for other people and
I noticed this and in fact at that point
in time these five top anchors hadn't
conducted 171 different interviews with
the venn candidates for president they'd
asked them nearly three thousand
questions
how many disposed mentioned the words
global warming or climate change
arguably the biggest economic and
environmental question any guesses ten I
heard somebody else to another cynic you
guys who's stealing all my just all my
material six it was sex to put that in
perspective there were three questions
about UFOs
so that's the relative seriousness that
the national press corps placed on this
issue now you think you know okay that's
2008 we've come a long way right we
can't we just had the Paris climate
Accords in December of last year
November 30th to December 12th of last
year right 195 different countries came
together for the first time have an
international core to begin rebuilding
the International economy and moving us
slowly off of carbon in the week
following the Democrats and the
Republicans both had presidential
debates one on CNN and one on ABC how
many questions you suppose the
journalists asked them in the Republican
debate about climate change zero right
but how many just posed asked in the
democratic debate one two five zero zero
so we really haven't made much progress
in the intervening years particularly
when it comes to journalists and their
ideas about contentious issues that have
political ramifications but that are
nevertheless driven informed by the
evidence science the foundation of
democracy and yet we can't talk about it
I don't care what saw what party you're
with if we don't base our decisions in
evidence we're shooting ourselves in the
foot because Nature doesn't care what
party we are this is a worldwide hoax
and his primary target was you the
people of the United States of America
rush limbaugh says James Inhofe senator
says the greatest hoax ever perpetrated
on the American people it's a
money-making industry okay says Donald
Trump it's a hoax a lot of it in 1920
ymr Germany similar comments were made
right-wing relativity deniers attacked
Albert Einstein's theory as a big hoax
and Jewish science these are terms that
are commonly used by authoritarians
when they seek to convince people that
the wool is being pulled over their eyes
and that everybody believes the way that
I do and this is a big ho
this world is a strange madhouse
Einstein wrote a friend at the time
currently every coachman and every
waiter is debating whether relativity
theory is correct belief in this matter
depends on political party affiliation
sound familiar part for winning the war
the book has several battle plans I'm
not going to go into all of them in
detail here I'm just going to skip over
the surface of a couple of them the
first and most important thing is to
realize that no matter again one's
science is not partisan no matter one's
party affiliation the great equalizer
and uniter and democracy is science it's
evidence from science and assertions
against science are made usually by
people whose position is not supported
by the evidence there are therefore
authoritarian one of the things that I
suggest we look at as a National Centre
for science and self government's to
promulgate policy develop legal theory
and model bills that protect democracy
and that encourage a more robust
democracy in an age when science is
having huge inputs into our policies
retraining the media and pro evidence
journalism and holding them to account
as for instance Media Matters for
America does by developing important
metrics on skewed public policy
reporting in the media to provide that
important back pressure on the media to
consider evidence as part of balanced
reporting as a friend of mine Don Shelby
says he's a Peabody and Emmy winning
news anchor really balanced reporting is
what he tells reporters when he talks to
them is that you imagine it not as a and
B but as a set of scales and you report
on the side of the story that has the
preponderance of the evidence the weight
of the evidence on that side granting
bodies we can there's a lot to do with
reforming granting bodies but requiring
and funding 5% on lab outreach would be
a really good start so that we build in
more science communication for the
health of democracy for the robustness
of democracy into the process because
it's fine to extend science way out on
narrow limbs of chains of evidence but
we are not bringing the rest of society
with us we're creating a gap that
creates a weakened science Enterprise
make knowledge more accessible and
integrated get it out of some of the
journals into a vast online journal that
is broadly searchable create model bills
to tackle science denial and the myth of
shareholder value being the sole
determinant of corporate performance
there is frankly no law that requires
corporations to strictly maximize
shareholder value as our Supreme Court
recently stated in in an opinion focus
on process versus outcomes in education
this is so important because it teaches
people how to think and how to make that
leap from sure it's fine to question
everything but then what do you replace
it with you have to go with evidence not
with the opinion of your best friend or
your political cohort faith leaders
actually I encourage them whenever I
talk to faith leaders that they had
joined the triple-a s and that they
equipped their flocks by four to live in
the modern age of science which we've
got all these immense complex science
and engineering issues that are facing
us they all have finely tuned moral and
ethical components that that priests and
pastors if they were scientifically
literate could actually have fascinating
discussions helping people navigate this
complex new world we're living in
coordinating science and the scientific
enterprise with disempowered groups
because science really does equate to
civil rights it's the foundation of the
idea of civil rights and there is not
enough of an emotional and political
connection there and refuting the myth
of the non interdependent self the idea
that my own actions are the only thing
that I need to take into account one
last step you could do is again as I
said sign on support science debate org
this was a project created just by six
people that went viral within weeks it
had 40-some thousand scientists and
engineers sign on in some ways that
transformed the science enterprises
relationship with politics in the way
that's
people think about it a couple hundred
universities does is a Nobel laureates
members of Congress CEOs or companies
join them you'd be in good company
calling for candidates to talk about
these things because if we get them in
the public discussion then we can trust
in this beautiful process of democracy
that we have developed to vet these
these ideas this thinking and move them
forward science debate org in 2008 and
2012 held online exchanges between
President Obama and his opponent Senator
McCain and Governor Romney between those
two efforts we made nearly two billion
media impressions in newspapers and
online publications and news reports
around the world mostly in the United
States creating coverage of these issues
that hadn't and probably wouldn't have
been discussed were not for this issue
so it really is true that old adage that
a small group of determined individuals
can change the world in fact President
Obama quoted our mission statement in
his inauguration speech and appointed
several of our earliest and most ardent
supporters to his cabinet so again
science debate org in 1948 Albert
Einstein sent a desperate telegram out
to friends supporters and other people
that he thought were of influence
arguing essentially that they needed to
support a new change in our dialogue
between America's relationship and
science and I'm paraphrasing here but
essentially argued everything has
changed
save our ways of thinking and I would
suggest that we're still dealing with
that same question so thank you for
listening and we'll we'll have a
discussion now
[Applause]
there we go I should also say that the
TV crew will when it comes to a QA
they'll be bringing around a microphone
that's not tied into the the audio so
the PA system in the room but it's so
they can pick up your question so please
work with them on that and speak loudly
we should explain the presence of the TV
cameras and all that as well as this
being videotaped for book TV which is a
c-span production so the microphones are
going to feed into the audio feed for
that program
okay you've read a lot of questions I
mean I've been doing science policy for
my whole career I was the head of
science policy at triple-a s before ruff
coming here to GW and a lot of these
questions are familiar you're not a
scientist how did how did you get into
this business I mean I started out as a
scientist and then I got interested in
policy and pursued that but look at your
resume and say where where's his
interest in science yeah I'm a bit of an
odd duck that way I actually I studied
kind of a combination of things physics
neuroscience and psychology and in
college I wrote my own degree at a
school called Macalester College where
you could do that and maintain an
interest in it although a lot of my
heroes were writers and I just wanted to
be a writer and I pursued that but I
became known in Hollywood as somebody
who would write about science and
Matthew Chapman who is a co-founder of
science debate dialogue and happens to
be Charles Darwin's great-great grandson
is also a screenwriter he wrote movie
runaway jury and
he's also direct redirect in the movies
alleged and he and I were up for
adapting Walt Isaacson's biography of
Albert Einstein and then the Hollywood
writers strike came long and we were all
without work and we had a little bit of
time on our hands and we were very
frustrated by the low quality of the
political discussion at that point in
time and how the candidates really
weren't talking about any of this
science tech health or environmental
challenges that we were facing and from
our point of view those have as large an
impact as economic challenges or foreign
policy challenges on everyone's daily
lives so we decided to try and do
something about it which led us down a
very twisty rabbit hole okay so you
you've written this book which you've
titled the war on science and you've
described it a bit but it sounds to me
like there is I mean the term war on
science is just an organized opposition
is this are we are we science advocates
facing an organized opposition to
science or is this just coming from
different quarters as you described in
industry and in right-wing politics it's
both it's both it is organized
particularly the industrial war on
science there's a large network of
grassroots front groups that are being
funded by the energy industry that
follow a fairly prescribed strategy a
seven-step strategy that I lay out in
the book and for instance Americans for
Prosperity one of them founded by
essentially by the Koch brothers is four
times the size of the Republican Party
so they carry enormous weight in the
American political conversation these
days and have a specific objective that
they're pushing and why do you suppose
they're doing this look what is their
what is their mistake in this in this
business how do you well from if you're
an oil company climate change is an
existential issue and
these days with 17 attorneys general
going after energy companies
investigating them and whether or not
they did in fact know that carbon
products fossil fuels were causing
climate change in the 60s 70s and said
about disinformation campaigns to
defraud investors in the public it's
very much an existential issue with
multibillion-dollar and perhaps
multi-trillion dollar questions hanging
in the balance I was intrigued by your
raising the issue of false balance it's
a-you know I see this myself and how do
you how do you get around this how do
you teach journalists that this is not I
mean this this is not the way to to
serve the public interest yeah it's a
big problem because the journalists
really is a generalist they're not an
expert in anything and so they would in
some ways be irresponsible by portraying
their reportage as objective when it's
not they have to acknowledge their
biases but at the same time where they
are falling down as I point out to them
whenever I have the opportunity is
failing to consider the weight of the
work of evidence and they need to
balance their reporting by telling a
story that is most supported by the
evidence and there are some people that
I point to that do this very well in the
book for instance I talked with
Stephanie Curtis who is the producer of
a program called the climate cast on
Minnesota Public Radio which is actually
distributed in several markets around
the country because it's the only weekly
radio show that actually gets goes in
depth in climate change and that doesn't
get caught in the details of whether
it's happening or not and it turns out
that once you get past that base level
political question the whole world opens
up as far as the fascinating questions
that you can get into about
how El Nino affects lakes in the Midwest
or weather patterns and things like that
and how we should be preparing for
coming changes so it's actually an
approach that could make meteorologists
for instance into almost anchor level
positions it could vastly increase their
importance to their viewership because
they are providing real solid
information that people need to know
this is a more speculative kind of
question and I've how do you think
future scientific developments are
likely to affect the war on science and
the opposition to the war on science and
to expand on that our run is there a way
to promote science in a direction that
will help in fighting this war on
science yeah well-worn science occurs in
in generally along two lines one is that
line when that has to do with
short-circuiting democracy in order to
forestall or curtail regulations or
bills that are going to affect your
business for your bottom line so it
usually involves public relations
campaigns in order to paralyze the
process or to get people to vote one way
or another and to provide them with
quote-unquote science that's
cherry-picked that that can throw up
uncertainties to challenge the
traditional mainstream science the other
is the issue when science presents us
with a moral quandary or with an area
that we need to as knowledge advances
that we need to refine our moral and
ethical understanding that always
carries a debate and it always engenders
concern from religious conservatives who
often are biblical literalists and don't
like the idea of science telling us what
to do so that's intruding on God's
territory so I think that there are
areas where that's going to continue to
happen particularly the the most
fascinating area I think is the
emergence of knowledge in neuroscience
and what that says about free will and
the inner inner relationship of
neuroscience and computer science
because if people have only a limited
agency and we can define when they do
and don't have agency and and what the
limits of that are what does that say
about our legal system and about holding
people accountable for their actions so
I think that there are a lot of very
interesting moral and ethical and legal
and policy questions that we're going to
be getting into in the next few years
there is just one example very good I
think that's a good point at which to
open us up to questions from the
audience and I see one immediately and I
see a gentleman over here with a
microphone on a wand
my name is Lee asked for your
presentation this is a certainly a very
good lectures but I think instead of say
war on science I think basically we
change the world science to justice and
a free fairness if we change to
substitute this world and you're no
political system will be off it into
this problem whether you have Republican
or whether you are a Democrat so if you
have me just mention about a public
comment
and the problem is for-profit
corporation whether the individual of a
religious call conquer brothers the
important things they use the profit how
the profit in their debate so everything
is really in terms of who get the most
money whether from consumers or whether
from the government so if we can
substitute is especially now if you see
that I understand they want to label him
mentally or literal so he is a great
scientist so if we just change you later
worrying about justice and fairness then
the whole thing we want to debate is
fulfilling to that so the projects are
people as a real conservation I love
them to control a lot of people to speak
yes thanks what is thank you thank you
it is about justice absolutely in
Sciences by creating evidence that is
impartial is of course the foundation of
not only our justice system but our
political system as well and so I think
that the emphasis on justice is actually
a very good suggestion thank you for
here let me remind you that these are
questions and in a question your voice
rises at the end and it ends with a
question mark
so and it should be no more than a short
paragraph okay I'm really sorry I'm just
sorry that holistic medicine and
genetically modified organisms were
swept into some of what I would agree is
really anti science where evidence is
denied but I would like to know what
you're basing that on because as a
medical researcher and a social
scientist I found that medical research
did not meet social science standards
often apples and oranges were mixed
together and yet the author's claimed to
have a definitive finding say about a
thorough stir OSIS when they had looked
at plasma exchange medications very sick
patients and still claimed to have a
finding and one last example would be
the NIH s examination of vitamin C under
pressure but then they said we're not
going to look any further back than 1982
social science tries to be as exhaustive
as possible so you don't miss anything
so what what we served did you use too
long holistic medicine as an
sighing thank you okay so I think if I
understand it right the question is what
research that used to lump holistic
medicine in as an anti-science I'd I
don't think I said a holistic I said
alternative although if by holistic
you're meaning things like homeopathy
for instance there is no scientific
evidence to show that homeopathy works
if you are when you're talking about
genetically modified food a lot of
people are thinking that that
genetically modified means some
additional ingredient that we're adding
to it or something like that and all it
is is actually a more precise form of
plant breeding and in some ways it is
safer than prior breeding methods but
where it gets into trouble I think and
where there is a politically important
issue is how its genetically modified
and for what purposes if it's
genetically modified to save the papaya
or to prevent blindness then those are
good purposes that like any tool science
is a tool remember that serve humanity
if it's genetically modified to make
plants withstand herbicides or or not or
well some herbicides and insecticides
that are essentially borrowing from the
environment by creating other problems
then generally there's probably going to
be some unintended consequences from
that and we're seeing that and I talked
about that in the book with the
emergence of super weeds so it's a it's
a danger to broadly say that all GMO is
bad to eat which is what is often argued
by those in the organic food movement
for instance that's not true there is a
political legitimate political
controversy about how it's applied
it's over here and then the gentleman
next to you with education where do we
start how do we start I'm concerned
about not only on college campuses about
trigger warnings and the things that
students get they don't want to be upset
yet if you're going to truly learn
I think it's learning is fundamentally
dangerous in my opinion where do we
start so that children and young
people's minds are prepared are opened
to receive information that might be
controversial because I think that's the
key to ending the war on science right
yeah good good question one of the
things when I when I talk to teachers I
talk about process a lot and about
different techniques that you can use
obviously when you're when you're
teaching young students you want to
create cognitive dissonance you want to
elevate their level of concern so that
they're engaged and then science shows
they're actually receptive to new
information because this is a solution
to a problem or the answer to a question
that they've raised themselves in their
own mind well what better way to raise
concern than to talk about politically
contentious science issues now
administration's often are uncomfortable
around that but student science debates
are a fantastic tool one that I often
talk about taking politically
contentious topics that are surrounding
science for instance making an assertion
vaccines do cause autism or that climate
change is human caused or is not human
caused something like that and then
assigning the students to research both
sides of the question but not telling
them which side they're going to debate
until the day of in which case you flip
a coin
when the students actually learn for
themselves some of the more interesting
differences between rhetorical arguments
or public relations arguments and actual
science and they're equipped on both
sides and they kind of
the difference so that's one interesting
tool that's actually a lot of fun that
doesn't have the teacher responsible for
taking a position if the administration
is uncomfortable about it another one
that I like to do is working with
students on the fundamental questions
like is something alive or not alive my
wife used to be a science teacher and
she would use a unit to explore this
with air ferns which if you know I'm not
going to tell you whether air ferns are
alive or not you can research for
yourself but but they're sort of like
viruses and that it's a it's it's a
fascinating area to begin to explore
some of the fundamental questions about
life in the universe and if you can
engage students in that and where the
answer is not readily apparent and there
are some twists and turns you can
capture their imagination in a way that
I think is very important because it's
not about regurgitating the right answer
which is not what science is it's about
an exploration of these big ideas that
we're still grappling with so those are
two examples anyway hi my name is Roger
Oliva I'm an engineer so my background
is science and physics mostly louder
please okay so I had a comment and a
couple questions the comment was the
people that need to read your book
aren't gonna read your book so so that
kind of leads me to my my first question
which is and what can we do about it and
I think you answered the education piece
perfectly I mean I think if you get
students engaged and that's you know
that's a great way forward but beyond
student engagement what does your book
recommend that we do about it and the
second question is just I'll ask the
same question in a minute but okay well
first let me apologize for the wisecrack
about engineers at the top or that's not
I was just having fun but alright
yes those who are authoritarian by
nature or who are predisposed in one
perspective about say climate change and
they're going to assume that this is a
book about climate change which is not
although it has a chapter that deals
with the industrial or in science which
is often fought on the climate front now
those people aren't going to probably
pick it up but their family members
might their friends might members of the
media I certainly hope well and by
equipping people with some tools to
think about this and to think about the
and to be reminded of what they may have
known and forgotten about the
fundamental role of evidence and science
in democracy I think will give those
people tools to begin to change the
conversation to at least feel equipped
to challenge some of the pithy talking
points that are being provided on a
daily basis to the other side question
was just what's the next book gonna be
well I'm actually I'm cure it's not I'm
exploring a topic right now that is
pretty fascinating to me about bear bile
actually and about her see her so
deoxycholic acid which was discovered by
a guy named cliff steer at University of
Minnesota and it slows her stops cell
apoptosis and it's a it's an amazing
chemical compound that's manufactured by
microorganisms in in our gut and it
appears in very very high levels in air
bile and no bear bear bile but for a
variety of reasons even though it can
it's it's kind of a wonder drug that can
treat Parkinson's and and ALS and all
kinds of degenerative issues it's not
being produced because of the structure
of our pharmaceutical system sounds like
alternative part about is that that it
involves the Chinese mafia I mean the
Bears are bears have been kind of there
by all has been eaten in their
gallbladders have been eaten for 3,000
years in china's the work of journalists
in places like the science section of
the new york times and if i mean i have
found as my name is stéphanie riche and
i try to be a quasi informed way person
and i have found many of their articles
to be very informative but what is what
would your evaluation be about a how
well do they do to combat this
information and how well do they
interact with other journalists who may
be so addicted to balance they avoid
evidence now I'd say that the New York
Times science section generally does a
pretty good job the problem is is that
there are so few science sections left
only 7% I think or less than 7% of the
members of the National Association of
science right
actually have positions in their field
many of them have to work in other
fields or work as science bloggers
because newspapers have cut those
sections by and large because they're
more expensive same with investigative
journalism sections those are the two
sections that really have been axed as
as the model of kind of free news on the
Internet has taken hold so it's a big
problem because here we are
ironically living in an age when science
impacts almost every big policy issue
and Sciences first of all ghettoize so
it never appears in the political pages
because editors don't put it there and
second of all most newspapers don't have
science sections anymore so people are
not even been given the information they
need to equip themselves hi my question
is really simple what is the role of
scientists in this war on science yes
it's a really great question yeah it's
simple and deceptively simple because
it's very important but you know the
most important thing I think is to get
out and be involved in the community and
be out as a scientist because we need to
reconnect that severed link between
science and society and the best way to
do that is by personal emotional
relationships that is how people make
many of their decisions and that's what
influences many people in their thinking
and right now polls show that the
majority of Americans can't name a
single living scientist even though
there are about two million working
among us like zombies yeah you just
touched on the topic I was going to ask
you I'm going to ask you about you said
touching people emotionally and
personally now with your Association and
Hollywood why not have sexy TV shows
that are all connecting the dots
scientifically and getting the people to
be a Sochi
with it connect them in their homes do
it emotionally because what's been
happening politically recently yeah you
know that's a great idea
there's the National Academies National
Academy of Sciences engineering and
medicine they actually have a program
called the science and entertainment
exchange where they work to do just that
they provide scientists as science
advisors to films and TV shows so that
they get the science right and they also
have somewhat of an ulterior motive I
think by informing those kind of
relationships between producers writers
and scientists so that they see that
scientists are actually generally pretty
cool people that are interested in a lot
of things often multi-talented and not
kind of the dry boring asexual people
wearing white lab coats and talking in a
monotone and a filmstrip so I think it
is having a positive effect although
still Hollywood has a hard time with
science we have to face it it's hard for
them to do comedies without making fun
of scientists you know making them into
either idiotic nerds or evil you know
mash inators and that's something that I
think comes out of that two cultures
divide that see peace no talked about
and that and that we're still struggling
with right now it's certainly something
that I would like to find a way to to
continue to make progress on and here
and one back there so start here so I'm
staying engineering right now but have a
strong interest in a future career in
science policy and as I've began to
interact with people who advise
congressmen on science issues they're
typically with a public policy or a
political science background as well so
I'm wondering if you have a perspective
of if that should change or and more
largely what the greatest impediment is
internal to the process you talked a lot
about the external forces that are
dividing people apart but internally how
can we mend this relationship and what's
standing the way absolutely one thing
that I tell scientists when I speak to
science groups is call your member of
and ask if they have a science advisor a
lot of times they'll say no in which
case volunteer and help them and say
I'll put together a team even and the
the thing about it is is that it doesn't
matter what their political party is if
you're providing them with the latest
objective knowledge impartial E you're
doing a great service and that's good no
matter who the member is the other thing
that I try to encourage is taking a
nonpartisan approach and I talk in the
book about kind of a structural issue
right now the problem with the way that
we do science advice in the United
States particularly the presidential
science advisor which is appointed by
the President and therefore is
inherently looked upon as biased by the
opposing political party sir Peter
Gluckman provides a really great example
of how to do differently I actually have
an interview in profile with him in the
book he's the science advisor for New
Zealand and he made a great decision
early on when he was asked to advise the
prime minister he said I'll only do it
if we if I can equally advise the other
side because I'm there for the
government and I'm speaking objectively
and the Prime Minister agreed and they
had a lot of problems with morbidity in
their teen population with a lot of drug
abuse a lot of teen pregnancy suicide
high suicide rates and they commissioned
Glickman to form a team to get to the
bottom of this and come up with some
policy solutions and instead of putting
together a team of stakeholders which
would be basically a team of vested
interests each with their own bias
coming together what to see what the
best biased compromise they can make is
he went to academics and scientists that
researched the question impartially they
it was peer reviewed both nationally and
internationally and they came up with a
number of different recommendations
the fascinating thing was that through
that process which was very transparent
at the end of it the Prime Minister
stood up and said we don't know what
these recommendations are going to work
because you know this is this is a new
problem so there's not a lot of history
on it but based on what we do know these
are the best recommendations and we're
going to go forward with them and he
hadn't looked men on stage with him and
they had tremendous support because of
that so the public I think has found
that really refreshing that approach so
as far as its kind of a conceptual
approach to science advice that's that's
what I would encourage and but in the
u.s. system as it is now
reach out in a matter of the political
party of the person and offer to serve
actually there's a I know a former
Republican congressman from Michigan who
tells that pretty much that story as a
personal story he volunteered as a
science adviser ended up as a member of
Congress is that Bernal Vern Ehlers yeah
Bern is a terrific guy in one of our
earliest supporters of science debate
you know in the back all the way in the
back
okay sir I just wanted to know if you
felt that it was being evitable that the
that science would actually win this war
in the long run concerning that
considering that to earth is finite his
resources of finite population is
exploding in the needs of the population
are going to become thorny and gone it's
going to demand scientific answers then
to resolve them to make a life on Earth
that much better for humanity and
society yeah okay yeah I'll repeat it
more broadly his question was because
the finite limits of the planet whether
ultimately science is going to win the
war anyway just because we're going to
we're bumping up against the limits and
with our increasing population and the
limited pasture or a limited field and I
think it's a certain extent that's true
although there are a lot of people who
question that a couple of people that I
talked to in the book Simon Lebon and
Jane Lubchenco question that pointing to
how science has repeatedly kind of
broken that that zero-sum game thinking
by innovating ways to increase the
productivity of the pasture of the
bounded field but I do think that
there's a very strong argument to be
made that for the that we're facing a
limiting factor whether science gets us
to a sustainable solution ahead of
nature is the open question I think and
I think we'd all like to manage our own
sustainability instead of nature
managing it for us because I don't think
that outcome is going to be a very
pretty one is a lady here with their
handle as a layperson I guess my
question is is that I think it's hard
there are things that we make scientists
make mistakes or they learn different
things and I think and maybe this has to
do just with reporting but
especially in the area of health or
nutrition there are claims that people
make rather arrogantly
I don't know whether it's based on
science or one of these other factors
but then people buy into that it becomes
kind of a fad and then pretty soon
you're off to another thing and what it
does is is undermines people's
confidence in what they read about
science and maybe this just gets back to
how science is reported I think you're
absolutely right a lot of it is how
science is reported what you're talking
about there particularly in the health
and the nutrition area a lot of that but
I'd say about 95 percent of the science
that you hear is absolute crap it's not
really science a lot of it is
industry-funded phony science that takes
advantage of journalism and journalists
of course love to get a sexy nut graph
and a nice lead and a great headline and
I outline a couple of cases where
scientists have worked to expose this by
for instance doing a phony study about
whether or not chocolate would help you
lose weight and using an a technique
called pee hacking where you sample for
all kinds of different variables and
then you with the advantage of complete
hindsight you look through all those
variables and you pick the one blip that
is statistically significant that gives
you a funny argument so you have not
actually done a double-blind study at
all you're statistically manipulating it
and then you can say oh well it looked
like people who ate chocolate actually
lost weight 10% faster and of course
you're going to sell a lot of chocolate
bars and and that's going to be on the
cover of People magazine or wherever
within a week so it is a big it is a big
problem particularly in the health and
nutrition fields in popular press
okay her question addresses what I was
leading up to here who gets to decide
what is the final word on what is
scientifically established on the
cutting edge of things things are fuzzy
things go back and forth
I've spent a career working in
regulation of toxic substances and you
have as you say things that are bogus or
you might suspect a bogus and things
that aren't but you in dealing with
epidemiology studies they're nature's
experiments they're uncontrolled and
they go up and they go down and mm-hmm
it's a mess and going going to the
National Academies of science
engineering and medicine they can do a
damn good job of going to experts and
getting a balance who biases and all the
rest but at the same time the science
has gotten so complicated and so
specialized that for a scientist in one
area to make judgments about results in
another it's not easy and I think for
instance this business about the GMO
crops and the feelings about that within
it is really really really hard to
expect explain to an educated layperson
who is convinced that business you were
saying about fear hidden dangers and I
must say that I have not as yet been
successful in doing so yeah well your
comment in question touching a lot of
important things one is that in the
absence of knowledge we often default to
fear that
for instance happened speaking of I
guess our engineer left speaking of
engineering with Shi Xing Xing who was
arrested by the FBI last year for giving
pocket heater designed to the Chinese
which was classified except that it
turns out that it wasn't a pocket heater
design at all and the FBI failed to do
the science necessary the the it's not
educate themselves necessary to
determine that and instead fell back on
essentially it was kind of racist to
bias the same thing happened to Achmed
Mohammed in the outside of dalit in
Irving Texas the kid who you know
brought a clock he designed a school and
and the police thought it was a movie
bomb they said and arrested him largely
because he was a Muslim kid with
electronics so when we don't understand
that's when fear and bias and the racism
sometimes in the form of violence often
take over our thinking and then the
other point that you made is that
science is often you know when you're on
the frontier things are not well-defined
it's not clear obvious this is hard and
a lot of times it is fuzzy and things
that may seem certain or
well-established now are shown that
there are not so certain down the road
this highlights actually a very
important problem in my mind which is
our reward structure in publishing and
the the answer is getting a variety of
points of view on this having a bunch of
people seek to confirm current knowledge
and it's particularly been highlighted
in the social sciences but I think it's
a problem in the physical sciences as
well that there is not a lot of
incentive for me if I'm running a lab
and to go out and do an experiment that
reconfirmed something that Betsy
published on three years ago I'm not
going to get any citations from that so
I'm not going to get any
new funding from that and we have a
problem because a lot of times studies
are out there that are only based on you
know published only based on one study
or one set of experiments and we don't
know as solidly as we should so we've
got you know science is an imperfect
imperfect mechanism but it's still the
best one we've got and the fact that we
can have these conversations about it
how to make it better as part of what
makes it so robust so okay I was going
to say one last question I see two hands
so if they're short make you ask each of
you can ask a question and then we are
adjourned after that okay so I was
intrigued by what you said about the
humanities and being underfunded oh and
and those folks are perfect for showing
the wonder in the beauty of science and
really getting to the gut response of
people so what do you say to the
humanities folks to bring them in on to
fight on our side of the war of science
what what can we do to help them along
yeah absolutely thank you for that well
one of the things that I try to do is to
point out the ways that when it taken to
an extreme
the idea of both of the ideas of
post-modernism are wrong and are
actually work to favor authoritarianism
instead of the opposite instead of
disempowering or instead of empowering
disempowered groups there they wind up
creating the opposite effect
the other thing that I try to do is talk
about for instance the great opportunity
for team teaching things like science
civics and talking about the way that we
evolved knowledge and going back through
some of the history that I talked about
today that's just fascinating stuff that
touches on so many big big questions
about what is the basis of law you know
well how did we arrive at common law and
and how does that relate to religion and
how did the word scientist come out by
comparison with artists in 1835 and why
did that discussion happen it was
suggested by a poet
actually so there are all these
fascinating interrelationships between
science and the humanities and the arts
and in a way sciences and art in fact it
was considered an art and tell it was
defined as science at that meeting of
the London Academy of Sciences so I
think that by going back asking those
big questions and in encouraging people
to reach out and bridge that that divide
CPS knows two cultures divided and team
teach on this and explore together we
can do a lot there's a tremendous
professor that I had in college that
professor Kim that ran sungkoo Kim he
ran a thing called I think physics for
poets or maybe it was called cosmos back
then I've been back to teaching it and
Lawrence Krauss has been there and in
the first time when I went there I got
to go to the airport to pick up John
Wheeler the guy who had just you know
named coined the term black holes and
all these amazing people and it was the
most inspirational thing because he was
getting at those core questions of what
is life and what is it all about and
that's how to capture people I think is
go for the imagination so thank you for
that I am a science communicator and I I
see some reason for optimism and some of
the rise of the blog's and citizen
science and I think the genuine sense
that geek means cool now whereas when I
was a kid geek meant not cool so I
wonder if I mean the war on science
sounds very pessimistic and doom
foreboding is there reason for optimism
are there changes that you see happening
that we can look to for yeah a source of
happiness and joy yes thank you for that
yes as I good thank you did you where
you plant there is absolutely reason for
optimism the human spirit is endlessly
resilient and innovative and
but we have to identify what the problem
is before we can work to solve it you
know that's that old I think a AC and in
certain ways it's it applies to anything
where we have to name a thing and make
ourselves aware of it and its complexity
before we can strategize around saltness
solutions and that's what I'm attempting
to do here with a striking title and I
do get into many solutions at the end of
the book I think that the generation
that the Millennials have a
fundamentally different view on many of
these topics much of this is driven by a
certain focus on the self that they just
don't have at the same level partly
because they've grown up tied to one
another with social media so they do
have an experience of reality that is in
part much more community-oriented than
some of us in the older generation and
to that extent I think that they're more
focused on issues of justice frankly
than they are on issues of self
opportunity and that gives me reason for
hope so I think that since to the extent
that science is a force for justice and
to the extent that being pro science and
being a nerd is cool especially in that
young generation I think that we've got
a lot to look forward to okay join me in
giving a warm thank you thank you
thank you and please thank my
co-conspirator alt a
[Applause]
my textbook purchase
like this yes yeah oh he was asking if
I'd sign in I will actually I'll just
say are here and they've gotten some for
sale outside and hopefully they'll have
enough if not I think that you can free
art it but I'll certainly sit here and
sign any copies that you guys have thank
you again for coming I hope you enjoy it